if there's something 2023 needs it's
more toxic men so Netflix has delivered
with a new season of you this season
seems to be a bit different with an
emphasis on a whodunit murder mystery
and someone seemingly stalking Joe we're
gonna be taking a deep dive into the
latest trailer and some of the clues it
gives us on what to expect if you
haven't seen the trailer I've left a
link to it in the description below but
before we begin make sure to like And
subscribe I'm planning on covering both
parts one and two last but not least I
may not cover every show you're watching
but when I do it's pretty cool our first
shot of Joe at a party in England who
now goes by the Alias Professor Jonathan
Moore Professor Jonathan Moore
why are you here if you recall we last
saw him in Paris at the end of season 3
in the pursuit of Marianne his Alias
there was Nick as we'll see a barista
call out his name Nick throughout the
trailer every shot featuring Marianne is
colored in these muted tones suggesting
everything that happens with her is a
flashback so something happens between
Joe and Marianne that forces him to flee
Paris and make the Trek to London it's
unknown whether or not the first episode
will set this up or if these flashbacks
will be peppered throughout the season
now look at Joe here he's not looking so
hot covered in sweat partaking in shots
with some of London's upper socialite
class the way the camera spins it's
almost as though Joe might be drugged or
it could simply be the effects of
alcohol this green shot here could even
be absinthe here we meet Kate who isn't
too happy when she asks him why he's
here he's alongside Phoebe and Gemma who
joke if he's here because he killed
someone or got his heart broken maybe a
bit of both in another flashback we see
Joe and his trademark baseball cap
keeping tab ABS on Marion at a train
station You're a murderer Joe you're
wrong about me it looks like Joe wants
to win her back and prove to her he's
not a murderer remember it was Joe who
killed her ex-husband and framed love
for his murder here's Joe at some sort
of upscale event perhaps an exhibit of
sorts at a museum this may be Kate's
event as she's said to be an art gallery
director on the red carpet Joe tries not
to catch the lens of the paparazzi as we
see Phoebe and Adam having their photos
taken so perhaps they are some kind of
celebrity couple or socialites Joe has
taken up a new job as Professor my guess
is he's teaching literature we get a
brief shot of Nadia who appears to be a
student who might be a little too hot
for teacher we're not quite sure but Joe
has fallen into this Elite social group
which he calls the most insane damaged
people on Earth and a circle of
privileged douchebags here we can see
them celebrating in 1920s dress and a
dude casually doing cocaine on the right
they even seem to be involved in some
weird medieval games Joe does give us a
little clue here but I do miss having
someone out there hinting that Marion is
out of the picture here we see Kate in
the apartment across from Joe's could
she be hostile towards Joe because she
senses something off with him or is she
merely trying to protect her well-to-do
friends who are often exploited Joe
tries to stifle his obsession for Kate
but when he sees her practicing her DJ
skills across the lane it's gonna be
pretty hard for him about halfway
through the trailer we get to what seems
to be the main plot of the season the
Eat the Rich killer who has murdered a
second member of this Elite group this
mansion from the news report seems to be
the same one Joe will spend with his
group of friends one of his students
says they're calling him to eat the rich
killer but I actually think this is a
misdirect there are no clues yet that
point to the killer being a man here it
appears Joe receives a text from this
Eat the Rich killer saying nice jacket
Browns your color now Peach and Beck
both attended Brown University but
that's probably just a coincidence the
phrasing here also suggests that this is
someone who knows Joe Joe confides and
Kate suggesting that one of her friends
is the killer but she tells him to stop
playing shitty Sherlock I'll share my
choices of who I think the murderer is
near the end of the video more Paparazzi
as Phoebe and Adam attend what I believe
to be a funeral perhaps of one of the
victims it looks like the professor is
getting some help from Nadia here who
says all motives always boil down to sex
money or Revenge which ties into Joe
stumbling upon a wall filled with
newspaper articles about his past kills
from season one to three this person
knows all about him even texting him now
do I have your attention a random shot
of Joe running through the forest
followed by Marion running through that
market from the beginning likely having
spotted Joe we also have Joe following
what appears to be Kate and judging by
their clothes I think he's following her
after the funeral to get a drink at that
bar Joe doing what he does creeping and
a Garrett wire hidden within a book this
looks like it takes place at the huge
castle Mansion the same one where a body
was found but I'm not convinced it was
Joe who did it considering the new news
report we saw earlier attributed it to
the Eat the Rich killer which I don't
believe he is this shot where Joe
scrambles to take off all the newspaper
clippings of him I found very
interesting for one it appears this
occurs at night while the clip where he
first sees them is during the day he's
kept these clippings up there for some
time but something has occurred so he
needs to get rid of them ASAP perhaps
someone is coming over this invitation
which states your presence is requested
at a night to die for I think is a fake
out it's likely an invitation to that
1920s murder mystery we saw earlier we
see more of our potential killers at
this funeral and a better shot of this
guy named Malcolm he's the guy that
brings Joe into his circle of friends
and also happens to be a literature
Professor himself perhaps he's the one
who got Joe that job more suspicious
shots of the various friends and check
out these two shots of a woman in Wool
throwing red paint onto a painting this
is followed by Simon a member of the
friend group throwing some paint as well
this appears to be his own work of art
that he's destroying since in the season
4 promotional material real we can see
him here painting the same picture of a
cat Joe and another member of this group
of friends Rhys are also watching this
transpire and knowing Kate runs these
art exhibitions it might be something
that was planned accompanying the
melodic sounds of a chainsaw is Joe with
protective eye glasses hinting that he's
sawing a body the lighting here even
suggests we could be seeing another cage
this is a great shot of Joe removing a
knife from a body this is interesting
because although the knife and body are
covered in blood Joe is completely clean
suggesting that he's not the murderer
and if you pay close attention to the
mirror in the background it's the same
one found in that room where Joe finds
all the newspaper clippings this could
mean that this body was killed by the
Eat the Rich killer either as a warning
to Joe or to frame him I don't know
about you but this looks like Phoebe
hitting on Joe Phoebe is supposed to be
with Adam so if Adam finds out about
this he might want to kill Joe for
Revenge but my guess is that this is all
a red herring Adam even says you still
spotlight and I murder you a shot of Joe
coming across something very disturbing
perhaps a dead body and the final shot
that of our group of potential Killers
now I want to briefly go over my top
suspects on who this killer is tied for
first place is Reese and Malcolm Malcolm
we barely see the trailer which could
mean he gets killed off early but he is
the one who works with Joe introduces
him to the friend group and is sort of
the Catalyst for this season it seems
Rhys on the other hand has a really
interesting backstory where he grew up
poor wrote this amazing Memoir gained
Fame and became a politician so he could
have a motive for killing the rich as
revenge for his childhood he would know
firsthand what it's like to be looked
down upon by the rich my number two pick
is someone not seen in the trailer Joe's
half-brother Jakey we've had flashbacks
of him throughout the seasons it would
be pretty easy for the writers to come
up for a reason he was able to track his
brother and give him motive to taunt him
like this number three is Kate at first
she's cold towards Joe but that seems to
eventually change as Joe opens up to her
and trusts her enough to suggest one of
their friend group is the killer in a
lot of these whodunit Mysteries it's
often the person who is the most
trustworthy and helpful that ends up
being the bad guy finally and this is
totally out there is that there are two
killers working independently of one
another but the press and we the
audience will leave it to be won now we
still have a month before the show
releases I want to hear your thoughts
and theories in the comments below of
what you think will happen thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
foreign